Film Courage: Three things you wish you'd known before
you made your first feature film? Mark Harris, Filmmaker: Oh my
gosh, three things I wish I'd
known before I made my first feature
film?
I wish out all right let me say this I
think because I didn't know anything I
didn't know anything at all about
filmmaking like I'm glad everything
happened the way it did because I think
had out this is me I think because I
didn't know a lot it made me want to
improve so many people wrong improvement
you know just let people know like look
I can do this I can do this and the way
I got into the film business is I'm not
different business but into directing
which actually I don't want to say by
accident but it was it was there was a
director who promises that you know I
write all these screenplays and he
promised that the screenplay that option
total be the next screenplay that he
write he didn't go through with his work
and at that particular time I was
emotional about it
I was angry about it but what I did was
I went out and I made my first film yeah
as I look back I'm thankful that he said
no cuz hey he made that for his film I
would never probably get on the set and
start to direct but once I got on set to
direct my first film even though I
didn't know anything I don't know
anything about filmmaking I didn't know
what I was doing I knew that this is
where I want what I wanted to do so I
don't think that's anything that I wish
I had of known because you know at that
particular time I could say well I wish
I had went to film school but I don't
wish I had what to film school because I
love I love that whole process of
learning as I go along learning as I
make different films in because if for
me
for me making it my it was like I was
film school for me and every time I was
I was screen the film I would get this
constructive criticism not only did it
make me a better filmmaker but that
criticism made me a better human being
that I probably would have received have
had I went to film school so as I as I
got that criticism I didn't go I didn't
think I would do everything I had to
listen so when you listen to the able to
accept constructive criticism that does
something to you to your character you
know so a lot of us again a lot of us
don't want to display our work because
of that of that constructive criticism
you know so there's no I don't think
there's anything that I I wish I hadn't
known going to going to you know I don't
think there's anything I'm blessed to
have to took the road that I took as far
as as a filmmaker I mean there's
something to be said sometimes for not
researching something and just trying it
as long as it's not life-threatening
because sometimes then you talk yourself
out of it mm-hmm and you go oh well if I
do this and it's not this then this is
gonna happen and so sometimes maybe it's
better to just say like you said just do
it and then you kind of learn as you go
and and with your first film you said it
was all wide-shots you didn't have any
close ups or mediums and so but if you
had been to like Precious about it you
maybe you wouldn't have made the first
one and then it wouldn't have led to the
second one i mean i'm just theorizing
here i don't see the thing is that I
think if I went to film school I
probably would have thought okay I can't
make a film for 5,000 oh if that first
film it was made for like a thousand
dollars I would like I can't make a film
for a thousand dollars you know because
in probably film school I don't know
maybe they're taught that you need a
certain budget but I wasn't thinking
about budget I wasn't thinking about I
thought okay I know I can make a film
for $5,000 I know I could make a film
for $10,000 so had I went to film school
I probably had that I probably didn't
think that way I probably okay I need
150,000 to make a film during that
particular time you know and so that's
why
I'm thankful that I went in that
direction because you know hey I'm
saying I have a thousand dollars I mean
just cause I'm gonna make a movie you
know and uh even though it shot it was
everything we shot in watch sighs I'm
grateful I'm thankful you know because
the next one we had our medium shots we
had our wide shots we're not close-ups
and then you know and you know each each
project you know I've seen it you know
grow and grow and grow
I'm gonna go get you know I'm always I
consider myself a student filmmaker
because I'm always learning I'm watching
my favorite I'm watching the interviews
I'm always cuz I always consider myself
a student filmmaker and I would never
ever escape that good plug thank you for
just one more time and it no I'm kidding
you